this week we're talking about moving
from 2019 to 2020 accessing VPC
resources from serverless code and where
to run your containers i'm jen person
and welcome to this weekend cloud where
we serve you the lowest latency news
we're glad to be back in 2020 and we've
got just the thing to start this year
off we've assembled some new year's
resolutions to guide you toward
operating a faster more efficient cloud
infrastructure check out these tips to
improve your skills and your
architecture and of course if you're not
ready to leave your 2019 behind we've
also got a recap of some of the biggest
announcements and stories from last year
from hybrid to databases to machine
learning a lot happen in cloud in 2019
so make sure to get caught up in stories
you may have missed and let them inspire
you for the new year if you've ever
wanted to access your private resources
from your server slap look no further
serverless VPC access lets you do
exactly that giving you an access point
that lets your App Engine and cloud
functions connect to VMs and other
resources with just a few lines of
configuration support for cloud run is
coming soon so don't let your VP see
silo your resources any longer did you
know there's three easy ways to run your
containers in google cloud alexis gives
us the details on how you can run
containers with your google kubernetes
engine cloud run and even compute engine
watch the video for more details and
stay tuned for more episodes of google
cloud essentials if you want to read
more about these announcements or see a
full list check out the link any
thoughts or ideas leave us a comment or
tweet us we'll see you in the cloud
you